ah yes
the good people at Sony assuredly made
this film because they have a passion
for the character and a desire to
faithfully adapted right I mean what
other reason could there be oh ok jokes
aside I am still morbidly curious about
this movie even more so after trailer 3
came out why didn't I do a video on
trailer 2 you might ask not enough
material to talk about and I'm not the
kind of channel that will milk a single
topic dry and do four consecutive videos
about to leak the images or some [ __ ] I
have some dignity thank you
unlike a me over here that making
something really good was actually made
economic sense but now I'm back because
there's content and this is looking more
like an actual movie with things in it
and stuff so in the past two trailers we
get a lot more footage of Tom shooting
black goo out of his or feces and
whatnot I guess they had more time to
finish rendering those effects like I
was talking about CGI looks well
serviceable it'll look better in the
final film I'm sure because it's a
trailer and that's how it works and I
don't know why people need to have this
explained constantly between these two
trailers I feel like there's finally
enough to go over and I want to take it
piece by piece let's start with what I
thought worked venom looks just how I
want him to
he's just the right height and size and
his facial animation looks pretty good
he seems like he moves in fights about
how he should - the webbing of course I
think the eyes and mouth look awesome
but everyone keeps doing these edits
where they warp it to look like other
stuff I can't tell if these are born of
dissatisfaction with his look or just
out of curiosity but I'm content with
his design even though he doesn't have
his iconic chest logo Todd it will
forever be funny to me that everyone is
now coming out as the sole creator of
venom because there's a movie releasing
after decades of being called
co-creators you gory seeking gas bags
the other symbiotes look great - and hey
we've pretty much all but confirmed the
five Venom's look we got this guy over
here is one of them this chick has a
symbiote blade thingy so I can magic
she's probably agony or scream and then
this dude and then this dude guy and
this dude bro turns into riot well we
got three out of five why not I know a
lot of people are up in arms about
carnage not being the bad guy but I will
reiterate my point from the other video
that he feels like too complicated of a
villain to introduce in the first one
you don't put the Joker in Batman Begins
save him for Dark Knight is that
comparison way off-base considering the
quality of these films yeah I mean right
it's cool look at him if that is riot he
actually kind of looks like phage to
Earl Asher you know what gets a lot hard
to tell them apart even the people
making the comic got confused
whatever he's a dude symbiote man and
whatever him and venom fight the imagery
gets super cool look at this okay also
look at that I appreciate little nods to
comic stuff to the shot of the venom
head looking at Eddie is one of my
favorite visuals from the comics it's a
literal devil on his shoulder the look
of the film is just correct
I like the designs the colors the look
of the fights it looks pretty much
exactly how I imagined venom would
translate to a film plus points on that
and well yes I'm aware that this doesn't
equate to quality storytelling and
acting I do just want to say that I
enjoy that individual aspect of it so
far and then of course I got to talk
about the thing I was really happy with
venom talks like venom which is like a
kooky edge lord who wants to scare the
crap out of people by talking about
eating them all day I think some people
are put off by venom making comments
like these but like that's how he talks
it was the 90s man it was a different
time he's basically doing that thing
violator does but venom is actually cool
so it's slightly less cringy slightly
like I know a lot of people imagine the
character is this big scary horror
monster that just runs around
terrorizing and eating people but if you
actually read the stuff he was kind of a
goof even as far back as his first
appearances he's making wisecracks and
singing strangers in the night while
chasing the bad guy
granted the turd in the wind comment may
have come across as a little crass but I
still don't find it that out of
character
a couple things I know they won't adapt
to the parts where Eddie talks about his
suit as his creepy lover eats mountains
of chocolate acts religious and then
gets cancer sure I guess there's a bit
of a tone issue present but for the
moment I'll point that at the company
that has to edit the trailer venom is a
serious and violent story with a mostly
goofy main character so the tone for the
trailer might come off as a little bit
inant between his dialogue and then well
everything else I get this vibe from the
action scenes that reminds me a lot of
the film upgrade not only because Tom
Hardy is nearly indistinguishable from
that guy but because he's a guy who
isn't in control of his body fighting
dudes while a separate entity is calling
the shots his brain I kind of like that
because it means Eddy in the suitor at
odds then they'll have to learn to work
together as a team more efficiently kill
this guy in a spectacular lee gory
fashion probably via exploding him with
a grenade inside of his stomach or using
falling debris to decapitate him I don't
know why those two specific guesses
sound right to me but they do now on to
what you all came here for bitching and
moaning time ok let's see what do I not
like I can't tell who's more
incomprehensible Tom party's
ever-changing accent or Venom's 4.1
billion vocal filters
Eddie sounds like he's gargling a
mouthful of Charlie who noms and Jay
Courtney's
find myself and God is this dialog
clunky again I can't tell if his
delivery is just that bad or if the
trailers are chopping up his lines but
it sounds like every sentence he says is
getting abruptly cut short - I have been
questioning something the government may
not be looking at I actually had to
watch these parts twice to understand
what he said I really hope that this
voice is subject to change and will be
more clear in the theatrical version of
course I could just read of it again we
need both your arms and both of your
legs and then we would eat your face
this armless legless faceless didn't
want you rolling down the street
I was right with that one shot having
unfinished CGI
I kind of hate that this is common
practice for trailers now because then I
always see this shot in the movie and
think yep I saw this before they
finished it
whatever happened to maintaining the
illusion I can't help but notice an
weighing is in these trailers less and
less and I feel like that's symptomatic
of her character having nothing to do in
this whole movie yeah that's about it
for me everything else seems fine I know
it tops everyone else's list though is
spider-man not being there and Sony is
reportedly scrambling and panicking
their asses off to have spider-man
somehow involved in this or the sequel
as we are all now painfully aware MCU
spider-man can't legally appear in this
franchise even though Tom Tom Amy and AV
have all expressed interest in that two
of them because they like the characters
they're playing and the other two
because they like money you know I'm
gonna get a lot of hate for saying this
but I think everyone needs to calm the
hell down about spider-man not being
there in my video trailer 1 I argued the
other side of the debate on why venom
needs spider-man but in the months since
I've reread a lot of classic venom books
as well as dawn Kate's his new series
and I think it's really changed my mind
on the subject venom doesn't need
spider-man to be interesting he stopped
being a spider-man villain decades ago
sure they fought a few times over the
years but he'd barely consider
spider-man his
anymore and they work together just as
often as they fight I understand he
makes a great foil for Spidey and he was
introduced with spider-man but Peter
Parker hasn't been important in the
character of Eddie Brock and so long
we've had so many stories about Eddie or
the symbiote doing stuff without even so
much as a mention of his name
I think venom has evolved past just
being a screeching maniac with a revenge
boner for spider-man even though he
didn't do anything wrong
granted spider-man is an important
element of Venom's origin but in three
hundred issues of his solo series Spidey
has only shown up about 12 times or so
depending on what you consider part of
venom solo run think of it like this
Deadpool first appeared as a random
one-off villain to job for cable and
narrowly avoid stabbing him in the dick
but then ultimately had cable appear as
an antagonist and Deadpool's film
adaptations who would then try to stab
other people's dicks The Punisher
started as a spider-man antagonist but
now people rarely associate the two as
being related munites started as a
werewolf hunter in some book for a
[ __ ] werewolf superhero no one cares
about Wolverine was an assassin sent to
kill the Hulk but now we get a trilogy
of films where Bruce Banner doesn't even
show up to the party even in one that's
adapted from a storyline where Hulk is
the main villain these characters are
introduced with one purpose but that
eventually changes they find new
meanings new goals new enemies new
desires new dicks to stab it's what I
love about comics is that the stories go
on for so long that we get to see these
characters grow and evolve like in no
other art medium I think a lot of us
Spidey fans have so many fond memories
of this rivalry from the cartoons and
the games in the early comics but venom
is in that one node anymore he's become
this street-level hero with a cheesy but
dark sense of humor that has ties to the
cosmic half of Marvel with elements of
eldritch horror that's pretty unique and
cool to me
so yeah does it suck that we won't get
to see Spidey and venom fight yeah does
it ruin Venom's whole character not
necessarily don't get me wrong there's
still reasons to hate this trailer and I
trust Sony to make a competent movie as
much as the next guy how dare you but
I'm still trying to keep an open mind
to surmise the movie looks about right
visually it has those neat little fanboy
nods and it seems to have a pretty
decent grasp of the character but story
acting and direction are all up in the
air I think everyone is entitled to
think it looks bad and not trust Sony
but don't just hate on it for the sake
of hating on it because it doesn't
conform to your personal idea of what it
needs to be a lot of folks have been
nitpicking minor parts all over the
place as the sole reason why it's
garbage but I think some of these are
silly a weird complaints and again there
are just as many legitimate criticisms
too and I agree with a lot of those all
I ask is that you judge it fairly
because none of us have even seen the
thing yet
it's not fair to assume a product is
completely worthless based on clips and
trailers
nor is it fair to say it's flawless for
the same reason objectivity isn't dead
just yet keep it alive boys and girls
I'm back to eating industrial quantities
of chocolate
[Music]
Hey look we got a new shirt design go
check it out you want a new shirt we got
new shirts go look at this new shirt the
cool new shirt oh look here's another
new shirt isn't that great
I think venom has evolved past just
being a screeching boner
look how comic accurate he is damn
putting a Nightwing machine